there are several beautiful beaches in
Gdansk for many impotant
it's considered a dream place to live
the protective sand dunes offer the
promise of a quiet life a quiet and safe
life is what this gated community is
supposed to guarantee strangers have no
hope of entering here uninvited
residents have to come and meet them in
person
Wojtek solution ski bought his apartment
three years ago as a successful
journalist his typical of Poland's
wealthier middle-class he made a
conscious decision to move into a gated
community we have an elitist lifestyle I
don't have to meet anyone here that I
don't want to meet like people handing
out advertising or homeless people or
anyone who could pose a threat to me or
just not fit in here Juba that's the
kind of luxury for me the source of a
safe clean and a good investment that's
how many in Poland see gated communities
so not surprisingly they're becoming
increasingly popular especially among
successful professionals Neptune Park is
another community just a stone's throw
away we meet with architect Arata
lawrence in the hope of looking around
the place which covers several Hector's
able to get past the locked entrance the
architect is not impressed
he takes quite a critical view of
Poland's trend towards gated communities
who buy an apartment here are not just
driven by security interests they're
sending a signal that people who don't
live here are inferior that their
children are inferior this is a division
within society that could lead to
tensions and conflict in the future
so much I prefer g20 Rosario conflict of
innovation conflicts have already
occurred the three sales is another
gated community residents here seem not
particularly interested in keeping the
peace with their neighbors those inside
the gates wanted to have the entire
complex to themselves from the chemists
to the supermarket the manager of the
supermarket says it's like an island in
the middle of the city the few customers
that come from the neighboring estate
are constantly complaining about the
fence they can't get direct access to
the hospital of the bus stop anymore
it's the same with the beach they have
to make a huge detour there are constant
complaints angry neighbors eventually
decided to remove part of the fence
themselves the security firm responsible
for the complex immediately came and
closed the gap but in the night the hole
reappeared the dispute has been rambling
on for months people who are very ill
need direct access to the hospital but
despite our protests they fenced off
everything they haven't even left us
just a narrow path it's so inconsiderate
so we had no choice we had to solve
things our own way and then she once
again hurries across the complex
trespassing on the ghetto of the rich to
get to the bus stop
gated communities are big business in
many parts of Poland there are dozens of
complexes in Gdansk and more than 400 in
Warsaw but the development surely comes
at a high price
critics say ostracizing poorer members
of society is a disaster waiting to
happen
even if it is private property no one
has the right to seal themselves off
with an electric fence and guard dogs
trained to attack people these
communities are still part of the public
space and they are there for everyone
and everyone needs to realize that it's
the flag when assisting you support me
despite the public criticism gated
communities continue to grow in
popularity and as long as the
authorities continue to earn from them
that's unlikely to change